what's up fool Podcast what's up fool
we're here man we're back well the
realtor they're too weak right two weeks
Lisa here I'm the weirdo steal errors
over there popping fireworks that's a
finger injured we have a guest right
here Brian Holtzman we'll get to him
through comedy jewel we're gonna get
down to the nitty-gritty bro asking
about the mustache just let me just let
me know when you want me to speak all
right what's up man what a football bat
wouldn't apologize about the last pawn
can we get through that you guys we run
a top of a helicopter so he will come
play another what did he want
we tried right they weren't good quality
audio
what's up fool man will you been bro
where I've been
Riverside on Tuesday night popping
firecrackers last night oh yeah fourth
of July Orlando of money net forces I
was killer dude what to my mom's house
for a little while eight burgers and
went to my lady's gram grandma's house
we burgers pop fireworks went home what
school buy fireworks with this guy right
and he was like sparklers whatever right
yeah the works you know
whenever they started that box in
Montebello you know that Barbies
Antebellum box Purple Rain yeah those
snakes so what I was doing I would do
dude and I'm waiting for him right up in
the back you know of his shop then a car
rose up and he pays the guy he comes out
with his big-ass box and he opens it up
he goes Mary Carol two of those and I
thought he'll give me just two cans
right but no man no those are six cans
for rocket so it's a tube and you put
the one right one can endure you shoot
it you gonna make you know you could
shoot a helicopter with like hanging off
the Blackhawk right there you wanna give
me to us to hell nobody gonna find out
what was it like going over there it's
like going to go buy a BB gun and this
blue shows double ak-47 scopes
everything but yeah buddy were good
[ __ ] fireworks that dude they were
shooting him at the Huntington Park
Police yeah better than those really oh
yeah so we got to see fireworks outside
of our house our neighbor we don't even
know her bro she was there her shorts
and [ __ ] an ID I guess whatever
MooMoo or low-cut t-shirt it was she was
popping her fireworks you know roman
candles skyrockets and then after
everyone should go to turn it off with
water it's funny everybody has a little
water buckets like eternity knows a kid
ninh with no water right Brian and no I
didn't see any throw safety right there
was nobody there was no throwing away
the firework we could have had those
short fuse somebody with a buddy that's
your cousin broke the wheelchair like
the roman candles myself hell yeah so
Abu Bakr the one you gotta buy eight of
them inside that little cylinder just
shoot them out looks like sprees like
those matter bomb I'd like to run a bike
in this shoot a lot drive-by so what's
our lad no fool hell yeah how how was it
oh my god dude the humidity
it was hard before you never you gotta
be you love your family man particularly
hot screaming humidity they want
lollipops everyone you the restaurant is
teeming oh yeah really love your kids
but the best is the year when somebody
urinates under on the blacktop and it's
really really hot you can smell the
urine wavering off the pavement it's
something else so what do go play out
maybe to golf bro so you guys just
driving or just a hole yeah it's like
Pirates have fun miniature golf in a
long time I love miniature golf she's
good at it she was the rapist I've never
done a record I was just three over par
for the whole course when I was cool bad
it was for fun
dude it was [ __ ] hot yeah man I just
hit [ __ ] you did I walk around no
teacher my teacher was proud and I got
to go to see at least those family
reunion shout out to the old Daniel
people they really good people I may
have died here oh the godmother kiss the
ring people hell yeah people telling lie
to talk to her she was in a car accident
or mall that they'd like to talk to me
yeah she like sits over there in the
chair and then smokes non-stop I know
that she turns out the cigarette in the
way you do a tortilla the bro she's like
frozen in this position Oh like her one
of her hands is kind of frozen like it's
just paralyzed like that but she has no
problem smoking that cigarette man to
get to her house he's gonna pass
security and then then I let you in then
he's gotta go over a little a little
bridge to get to the island where other
house in the right dirt-poor you know
literally cocoa beans cocoa be there in
like something Indian Hill something
manatees out there you just leave like
the canal you know someplace to brew it
they parked there born in stays in the
water in their neighborhood they have
like a lift I lift it up and it stays
open and up in the air so I won't get no
bar no cause nothing and the ball stays
no that's money yeah when they can do
that that's real money everybody
everyone else both around you know who
lives there but how clean their boat is
if your boy had barnacle the year end
abroad
you probably there a delivery of [ __ ]
music but everybody their words bring
her whole family Angelica
in lower a cousin that he's a doomsday
prepper you know he had the conversation
like yeah man the way we're gonna make
no money Madeline you're you're Kennedy
or Rocco father yeah he's a rockefeller
okay he's smart but right but don't
expect me to ride the boat got it I'll
figure out how that right you want to be
in the military touch this guy hell yeah
guess stories bro light like they are
like yeah Mellie
he got those guys on the Gulf War they
looked on the guys would the first time
there you know it yeah you gotta be a
dumb guys you know who looked at us you
know because we're not really embattled
my well you know what it was still out
there everywhere I lift a to a dark one
black flag all right three bars four
bars ready but the house is huge bro the
house look like what a little houses bro
that you see why people in like in a
soap operas like Santa Barbara or Dallas
Dallas yes you know the swimming pool
bro the palace boy like you shouldn't
have a changing room at like her aunt
could make money shoot letting people
shoot video than Apple thing that cleans
the woman yes a bidet but they bro was
my feet there that night bathrooms bro
nine go to your room was ready they were
a screaming room bro like reclining
couches she can't go anywhere though
they don't go anywhere so she has
everything at her house you know the
team of boxing you the whole time over
there hello but huge TV bro and then it
went to America's Got Talent some little
girls singing oh my god
check out this girl she like her whole
family were a bunch of Horlicks she
lifts them up there well they're there
because they're just all dirt poor
family attend kids and you know and so
yeah she she she started this business
after having nothing in the in her
parents-in-law parents-in-law his
kitchen and she started this business
selling headsets and then it turned into
an empire and she employed her whole
family and brought them all down there
in Florida and they they became
middle-class um she's more than middle
class but like came from nobody I
finally could say she never took care
because you do make a phone call you
gotta be really like but she hums
they're not they're down like that
they're worse in like you know problem
just come with Lord Oh take care of you
I know family member man you help
animate you help them have it that's
funny you help with a job they do well
you get money they fail huh how somebody
with money if they're in the situation
because they can't handle money and now
you gonna give more money to keep
messing up well we all money man like
$1,200 all man sheets is up you know how
you watch people's videos and you think
that only people even a good life right
but the day I found out I saw a video of
this girl and her [ __ ] hooked her her
house was on fire
and I said okay house on fire but wasn't
really a house bro it was shitty an
apartment and they let the oven on and a
fireman showed up brother you can see
how how bad an apartment is like and we
want apartment you can lean like this
and if a gang member who live next door
what's up man past the grape oh yeah
we're over there cheerleader she told me
they showed up what's up fool summertime
summertime bro you know how it is man
I'm sweaty bro
I'm back to to 289 and a good day you're
right tight like that lady in Orlando
said ok no Ellen DeMayo
in theory we have for some good food huh
only Cuban food oh that lady Cuban salsa
cafe oh my god there's a cafe man Cuban
coffee
no party in there they'll play me up
salsa music the whole time in the
morning now that's on pain you can't
even hear you order okay oh so joyful
and body type or a kilo the oil go cover
Tito let's go number two number two I
wasn't the best part right there
delicious bro you have passed out huh I
had to take a nap too I'm sleeping it
before it's hard sometimes out for hours
of sleep but you just kind of power
what's up fool all right man Oxnard in
every live coming up upcoming shows oxen
are literally live July 19 through 20
second I'll be there with Rodrigo Torres
Johnny rocky and live near Popovich so
go check that out
Jacksonville Florida comedy zone August
2nd through the 4th I'm a riddle Texas
August 10 McAllen Texas August 11th love
back or a little bit Texas is a big
state yeah August 24 no ray no Texas
August 25th
how we been there Lorraine oh no they
were this [ __ ]
that's Brownsville okay Rosie Maria
California Labor Day weekend man we're
gonna be barbecuing vegan burgers right
outside of parking that that's the new
brand prov now do they have a big old
like screen up in the front saw like
high tech digital not inside it was like
a couple bills baby it's huge
- Norma's they were officers patio right
they're supposed to have a rooftop but I
don't know if I got approved I don't
know what the deal is but yeah who the
first communion there I think it was
Dana Carvey
i racing to the moon yes my role was
tough we salary bubble brown drops
around urban god yeah well he was with
us in uh I told you Texas San Antonio
and shout out to everybody who showed us
that our people showed up deep was so
full podcast we do complain about the
way the whole time let's read these
comments go for what so Felipe the grass
at the Reunion that's right bro
out a reunion it was me and another half
Japanese guy let's go to the top row
read these comments what's up fool hi
Lisa is mega man in the house what's up
or Patrick makes whole are fat
middle-aged man podcast you know what's
up dog we love the nineties Steven
Martinez what's up sometimes I play with
my boss hey I did too well you know this
stuff that males do it we all know we do
it but when you share a bra it makes
them all alike perverse bro don't let
that bro just keep it to yourself bro we
all jerk-off we all go down with chicks
when you put it out there bro it's what
it looks nasty bro that's what I mean -
came out what's good Felipe know what's
good bro your sister bro how she did
Francisco they have soos he's a soldier
he's here every weekend every week
listening this is the Late Show dope but
I'm at work Omar Gonzalez a little did
alright
what's up fool I saw Sicario oh hell
yeah I was at the premiere oh yeah I was
telling everybody he's a tourist stop
man
it's double oh yeah man oh man you know
like man so I always thought that when
you go to premieres they give you like a
bag with a t-shirt a basket a gift
basket or a sick idea or a holster
[Laughter]
sometimes you do get a little swag like
that yeah yeah better a little swag a
little bit good you know walkie-talkie
[Music]
that movie bro it was better than part
one it was better than telling one and
but also meant the soundtrack songs man
would you sound it's a creepy noise like
like you're a bomb
like a brat Holtzman was looking like
out of a helicopter bro as Mexico and
looking for narcos this beautiful plane
[Music]
his mustache is perfect for it yeah
people don't like it my family doesn't
like it that's what you have you babies
a blonde bro listen here big fan Felipe
of course Chris Deadpool for 20 original
what's up fool Eric Cruz where does not
just come on comet on shitake way when
you in stand an anti California you know
what I'm in Santa Ana bro when I'm going
to San Diego and I'm passing by on the
22 freeway I was it was fun hanging out
there show Thank You boys for the
hospitality who are you and where did
you hang out
one more toy yeah hell yeah Oh J
Barone's that's one right
who told Lando improv was good you guys
have a good for of course we did bro so
I'll have two Premiere Pro free popcorn
I don't like always yeah but what's a
lot of actors here bro like a man and I
actually I won in a movie bro I saw I
saw it wasn't named a UFC fighter again
Tito Ortiz Tito Ortiz hmm I saw look
peewee but I stay right in front every
man he will bootleg in the movie though
they lost the Iceman Chuck then a bunch
of other people fool oh cheese was there
bro the amplifier demean them and I say
I already met him I'm trying to get over
someone stuff right my ham goes a long
way just be lecture here how to conduct
myself in the red carpet there's rules
so man Jesus oh man I want the red
carpet I will let the gather was selling
[ __ ] beef on the hoof sir I was
commercially so I thought let's check it
out bro watch the video hit play watch
the video for you check it out for
yourself you got to tell me what you saw
where's that volume I'll be the value
away what's up hold on what no I'll go
over there right now I might think of a
mask here unless you watch teeth to take
a photo with me
hold on teeth oh no I gave up to take a
photo with me
hold on people get new teeth in there
for their mouth busy or asking right now
for a photo
everybody looking back with you it's the
woman from the Jenny thank you so much
some rotted past by Sicario yes I don't
know who these kids were man but they
were like ROTC or some cadets
for some military Oh representing Mexico
that day Mexico logical deal by the way
so I'm waiting super I'll go over there
this was just the same way all the time
at weight I hat looking like we look
like the most interesting man in the
world so there's the red carpet people
is how it goes down you know they'll
show you around
a man so I hope to hear my say no photo
he was no hell no man I got a this will
say no man
what no I got a boat to pick and say
what boat to pick you ate all the meat
[Laughter]
I'm all butthurt you know my face
looking like a little boy who's tired
eating over here no tomorrow for Thor
but you got my [ __ ] sweater though
but I was like they're bad what's up
with that I bow to pay but I never bow
to you know I don't know what's going on
already Lee right now somebody give me
some water
anyway so I'm chilling looking like
Beastmaster right here thought my
publicist over here that girl with the
curly hair man who Oh at my bro
everybody's asking who is this guy right
here I'm pretty much talking [ __ ] right
here what up you guys wanna watch what
I'm saying right here go to the Facebook
live right there
this chick right here we were together
plus a Neto her name is I'm Eddie
any guy time eating that time this was
say what happened back there I don't
know what happened bro but I can't watch
you feel at the [ __ ] numb though we
do you ever can what you see here with
the [ __ ] door slamming SummerSlam me
it's gonna be held Echo Park will even a
referee
well sabe yeah man so I'm still I'm
still looking back you know like John I
think about what could I do it so maybe
right here I'm talking moisture saying
man you know what matters
we just can't let you go we're up we're
all grown-ups here we're not even in the
[ __ ] movie man I understand we're in
the movie and we didn't get a lot of the
movie set but we're never in the movie
Oh everybody I'll show me around man
come on man don't instigate you fat ass
did you have your first [ __ ] red
carpet so we go Lisa could tell you the
rest if she wants she was there but we
go I just did forgetting him I [ __ ]
three popcorns I'm acting like I stole
it but like I came up but it was free so
I'm right here doing more more
last-minute thoughts about what happened
back there pretty much gonna take a
photo just like I felt like George Lopez
when he I asked Erik Estrada except I I
know this food so I go say it out and I
forgot about it already right forget
about it you know so I'm just chillin
I'm I'm mom [ __ ] like chilling and
then lady comes over give me a lecture
on why he couldn't take a photo like a
lecture bro you know what happened we
just kept talking bro I'll show him a
light he went over here love it together
he had new 45 minutes bro so yeah man so
I what happened bro that's not snow bro
red carpet gangsters wine oh right so
that's perhaps the second to take a
photograph I don't take the second right
everything to go you you're a piece of
[ __ ] Felipe what you talking about me
losing my virginity
you know what I mean
that song could have took Y you could
have just said hey hey hey even when I
read it to Jo koy I kept this mo bro I
mean it was surprised yeah you know
you're gonna be [ __ ]
professional right right bro great I'm
not asking for little bit I take my side
but you know how it is bro you gonna be
professional where can I catch Filipe
Esparza show bro Filipe with WorldCom's
last tour what is he
yeah Osvaldo yeah bad you know what
Brian
I think Gabriel se is going through a
dark period in his time you know and
it's tough bro you know like Martina out
there man to talk to him is sad after
Robins only there from the shows what's
up fool that's what happened man I was
all sadly awful bring back my team but
don't [ __ ] podcast yeah man so that's
what happened man I will put a hit on
him
what's up fool so what someone's either
man what you do or the video man damn I
guess he's bummed out that you did that
little story so do you wanna take a pic
but I mean [ __ ] out to the pic do what
sobre hos man minute there is one and
why I was asked to be here today was so
cool later gentlemen I brought you
something I I mean I I used to work with
you at the Laugh Factory late and then
and then I never saw you again and then
I was at the Dodger game once up another
top of the top deck there and I said
that no one that hair looks familiar no
one wears their hair quite like that and
sure enough it was you throwing the
first pitch out yeah Dodger game so this
is the first time I've seen you you just
blew up you just were there and then you
were gone wasn't it mm-hmm so this is
for you
these haven't been worn
pick the one you want that one's the New
York Central Park
this one is Dubai they're extra large so
they you can grow into them thank you
for having me on the podcast
I'm a huge endeavor take you man yeah
got you want to a purple one and a white
one
what's up fool this will stay here our
fluffy little journey broke many times
on a podcast we have mentioned your name
Brian Holtzman and I think we had a
bunch of other comedians that we talked
about you
we had Johnny Sanchez here we had I'm
sorry we had we had rehab bro on the
company store old school
Johnny Johnny doesn't know what he wants
D del rey mexican are you white what do
you want to be you know it's confusing
whenever you talk doesn't know how to
speak Spanish knock off the real deal
Holyfield fool so bad and I talked about
one time up you were with you you were
one of the foot oh yeah al Bourbon in
the show so you're one of the first
comedian I met at the natural budget
Brenda Brenda Johnny Roberts everyone
for the nut burger how did you start
doing stand-up comedy and how did you
end up there I like when I meet you
there when I came to Los Angeles from up
north
that's you throw up my lord we're up in
the Bay Area that's where I started
doing comedy because I said to myself I
said you know I don't want a family I
don't want a wife I definitely don't
want children that's gonna leave a lot
of free time I better figure out what
I'm gonna do in the evenings that was
pretty much it
pretty much yeah I need to fill that
space thanks thanks for having me thanks
for having me guys then I came to LA and
I you know in LA it took me quite a
while to get into the Comedy Store so I
was doing the open mikes and that's
where we met
yes I met you up there
I'm international at the Waldos comedy
station right Hollywood Hotel on Sundays
without don don right Don many went
there but Don white and then her it was
dawn in Chris and then her dad he's to
staying bro but it was crazy back that I
remember old crooner huh yeah I remember
1996 man I was doing common like a year
and a half and we gather that's you know
laughs festival right and and I met your
mom we were on a boat together
all right all right we were on a river
but I won at the River Center River Walk
at the River Walk bro hey man I and
phrase Thoreau and Darren Carter Darren
Carter famous story about was yeah I
don't know who I was when the younger
comics you know I forgot their names but
I remember Johnny's not just - I think
oh yes he was there yeah he was
pretending to be you know Portuguese
yeah the one thing he told me was
Portuguese yeah Iberian Peninsula it's
closed right it's hard to nail him down
but yeah the Latino laugh fest I would
have long hair in a ponytail
yeah I think he wanted to be an Indian
then and this right I'll do it
comfortable a brand new and I will see
him go well bro and just talk [ __ ] bro
about Brenda Lee over you [ __ ] your
brother you [ __ ] you're stuck you
stand asked it's like that natural [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] yeah like raw bro like
really fountain a lake like she's
spilling his whole fine man it just
ripping her apart tight like instead of
everybody up there with notes he goes
what the [ __ ] out through the [ __ ]
nose for like this shows gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] you like he's about to [ __ ]
everywhere if they make me [ __ ] you
brother your sense hits those tits a
door bright there's never like there are
tapes that were like 34 they were like
32 bees at one time
now bro if they look like one of those
sacks like an Lord Benton that's here
like a [ __ ] altar where a look like
are notated look look like flat broke
and look like one of those little pouch
oh you put wine in there bro and you
take him to go hiking yeah and then I
wanted to see the whole gunpowder bro
[Laughter]
first confidence goes just had it bro
like getting him a [ __ ] bro like
everybody's dying for I mean died other
young comics on Jimmy killing it was
that he was young it was us and then
system essentially it was me and that
would I feel like I feel like they're
seen in Goodfellas like walking into
[ __ ] working into the natural fires
you know yeah man it was it was Johnny
robbers in his [ __ ] same [ __ ]
super there was always clean and Brenda
with her sad tears and it was out
burning over there and Johnny Sanchez
theater Levine and Alonzo Bodden
and you know and then the Molly twins
moody twins and who is that Eric Edwards
the chubby guy bro he left a lot of way
boy he wasn't in that movie pchew or
something yeah he wasn't [ __ ] that
movie uh kids at home assemble yeah he
was at home alone my three sons just
Jethro and Beverly Hill Beverly Hills
Beverly Hillbillies he was uncle Ernie
he was does it or me mmm Eric Edward is
the guy is it Erica were the catawba
comedian man he used to he used to close
his act by putting his leather chuck in
a leather jacket in and putting his
jihad the way up and covering his pants
and making his hair weird like a
pompadour and then like having the light
came on him and he'll have a cigarette
and go rebel without a race
wastes light JD crowd-pleasing
people love it people had long closers
backed it up right yeah that place at
the natural flood road was too comedians
and then I don't know why we're brand I
would put on like punk bands in between
so they're setting up behind you
these [ __ ] are gonna make it you know
but this will be [ __ ] you're banging the
hard aughh
you know [ __ ] play a song you know
util skinny [ __ ] you know get off get
off yes oh Jesus in Adobe ID you only
get two songs that's it get the [ __ ] off
we want to do comedy here Brenda you
[ __ ] get them all right and now I I
remember that I went to I went to the
comedy store I was on a Sunday or
Saturday early JV Kenya was there
Deadwood
yeah and you were there and you said
that Brent and they said that uh bright
they're jolly robbers die for the Metro
fudge first he had a stroke yeah then he
died and he told me she go pay your
respects you know so I don't know why
but I went over there right and and I
wasn't there mom no the lady was dying
she was crying broke she was crying by
the bar you know seen by the bar sad
crying giving out free drinks
she knows his over bro Johnny Johnny how
they talk shutting hell [ __ ] he held
the whole place together bro right he
had two [ __ ] TV local axes there then
like I told her sorry about what
happened
oh I'm so sorry Philippe but thank you
for showing up I turned around bro and I
could turn around and I see her making
out with one of the best it makes the
waiters that's our Brenda closure like
Mickey though he's not even in the
coffin yet roll let the healing begin
yeah they do Brock you have to see with
her for good spots put me on me foot
right before the punk man
what's up fool man so so you um you do I
just have a lot of open mics but your
[ __ ] was always like raw manual real man
like a lot of people say that oh man
that fool edgy or or man he's crazy now
this little crazy done real thing I just
over one time this airplane crashed like
a Saturday night and see how everybody
was a car bro this fool picks up the
show wait I hear American Airlines is
hiring then he said out Brian said you
know everybody talks about [ __ ] about
[ __ ] now I bought all these hack
Congress talks about [ __ ] they put me
back to the black box you know -
everything survives when I make the
[ __ ] now why not make the whole plane
out of the black box - [ __ ] your hat
comics you know who survives to babies
when I [ __ ] your seat next to a baby
make the whole plane and I'll [ __ ] your
babies so what happened in San Antonio
man it's full of birthdays dawg like I
know so I was so excited to go there you
know and guess who goes up right before
me call him and see a blue bumps no bro
can't get like is this bright host miss
movin bro like he's supposed to go on
television you know everybody went up
Freddy soda was supposed to go right
after Brian Holtzman I got off Johnny
went up after me and then call him and
see I went up begging to go up and but I
don't how do you how do you do that no
time to shine just bald there's there's
a big brain hoes cuz wasn't there a
crazy thing going on cuz he was with HBO
and this was a Showtime production he
couldn't be on the TV part of it yeah he
snuck he couldn't do the show because
they were short to having him at HBO
deal but he could do a guest spot
unfilmed yeah people booked that week so
he flew
oh yeah I flew right in all the way from
LA you gotta bomb completely and never
know I perform but it was anti-climatic
you have to follow in him then I'm
bright Mitzi shore was there bro
and she three nights to a bride hoping
Michael she's like what's going on why
is why is Carlos even here so so the he
didn't like 25 minutes I know Jenna they
would do think it off get off whatever
right they just we have to go up now bro
after miss here killing it destroyed it
you know they should have what they
should have done is put up maybe Freddy
solo up and then another Latino comedian
and then Brian holds me now but then he
goes up there and he just turns it to
Brian host man for that about the five
innocence he says since is not a comedy
show I work for I&S there's there's um
they're gonna knock on the door
everybody who's gonna get deported see
it was a bust
it's a bust everybody on the bus and
then I said I said I know this is a
Latino laugh festival because the paper
paper towel dispenser in the bathroom
hasn't been touched so they wanted to
just light me up but after that I didn't
care my mother got to go to San Antonio
that's all I care about
[Laughter]
shoplifting book never convicted he
could have birthdays
there he go they inspire you know you
could watch yourself because you know
what happened you know but like we will
you already bro then he's up there and
he goes oh my god [ __ ] shot she'll car
shoplifting this morning they were
convicted not just a charge was so full
right Horseman yeah so you work where
Comedy Store with the Friday and
Saturday nights yeah
I remember at The Comedy Store bro I
have to watch your brother do legs start
breaking him you're the only one I make
bang on [ __ ] Chewie on the throne
chewiness a [ __ ] jury
I haven't seen him I think he went to
Las Vegas you know Chewie
yeah the musician used to be the parking
lot dude can't park there
bro bro you can't park there bro bro you
can't I'm a common cool what do you mean
I can't park there
oh I'm not one of your customers that
way I can't park here
[Laughter]
yeah Chuy Castro
so what when you started at The Comedy
Store man well there's a lot partying
going down oh yeah 94 yeah used to party
hard Oh a bit yeah just I had a special
rail I would go right from the comedy
store right to the rainbow job yeah the
uber to the rainbow bar next to the
rocky inside being a play to do drugs
there's a bomb and mozzarella sticks
here that's a relic you that's a lot of
cubes
they're like mozzarella sticks of bread
and cubes of cheese they were so good
this guy said rails on Rails Thank You
Francisco now shut the computer off and
go to bed so you started the Comedy
Store
yeah it took me five years to get here
and finally she let me perform there and
then they've been spoiling me ever since
you know case I could be a you know
I remember at the Laugh Factory
I will get my one o'clock spots right I
used to work together right and I missed
you and now you're gone it with me here
with Tiffany Haddish
and sometimes Leslie Jones Leslie Jones
and Brian hos will go up at 1:30 or 1
you know who's running the club now
what's his name Jay Davis Jay Davis he's
the one I used to do that show of
Dublin's right Jericho there once Jeff
Vaughn once is that when you choke that
hooker he goes
you go like yeah man now uh they put it
up no parking no parking sign on Sunset
Boulevard Oh morning I mean where's the
guy supposed to token vocal choke oh
choke a hooker they throw her off the
road if you can't park there well where
am I supposed to [ __ ] take her so we
do doing the demon your regular job
right if we I used to work at the
airline the airline right right as the
what buy a mechanic chief I used to be
the if the pilot for the Pacific routes
first officer and then and then you know
I got sticker flying you know it's it's
kind of stressful your ass was flying
please captain speaking
all right I need your picture like
somebody was sorry she bailed on or if
you don't want to that's okay too I just
pictured like somebody was just saw he
said a man they kind of my [ __ ] pilot
no he's telling somebody that I'll just
dig it up the ass
[Laughter]
you had a gun pulled on you right one
time a Latino show yeah Willie Barcena
oh yeah to this day I have to thank him
yeah Willie Barcena broke my life he
chopped the gun he he like what was that
there Willie Barcena used to have a room
that was crazier than wild than Gotham
Emma Gotham's crazier than wild coyotes
man with our bikers bro it was mongos
and whatever cholo decides to walk in
there on a better way another one a
better way the tequila's right to kill
us well tequila yeah it was unbelievable
he he came out to the parking lot he
said he came up to me real serious he
says Holtzman you got to get out of here
and the gate was coming down because
they wanted to lock me in I think and I
just got out in time to this day you
know they they they took it serious what
I was saying you know they were gonna
cut me I think they were gonna cut me
but he saved my life to this day I'm
grateful to him welcome where does he
live now Silver Lake
oh he lives in town yeah he doesn't
soberly write with family in the podcast
though right he performs do a long time
and then I did one with Marilyn Martinez
and her brother David was there and it
didn't go well at all
see if they take it serious then they
get offended then it all goes south you
know if you're not if you're gonna take
it serious of course you might get upset
your stuff is pretty borderline [ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was just some dicey talk cuz I
don't want to get cut just messing
around yeah the guy they go abroad and
she took a gun through the whole show I
think right even see it was part of that
show - yeah what job will you save
your TV the TV clean said Oh probably
something about a leaf blower or some
[ __ ] like that don't buy your show a
leaf blower your girl's ass yeah did you
just bend over and just pick something
up just one day you have to wake
everybody up with that [ __ ] machine
and they got very offended you know it
was part of the one you said about your
arm your joke about half how to handle
immigration problems right yeah you put
them on it go to Home Depot and you pick
them up and a big pickup with the double
wheels in the back and you say I got a
big job big job everybody in and you
just cram them in as many as you can and
you drive down to Tijuana and say
everybody out out and then you come back
and you do it again and again and again
and then I said I think what pissed him
off as I said I knew this was a Latino
show because there's a whole bunch of
leaf blowers out front they just take
that serious real serious then the
people get pissed they like when Latinos
didn't get pissed off white people got
pissed off at his homeless jokes you
know one joke about how you'd have no
friends so you think I think you're the
homeless guy in the carpool right
they go they're dropping off you know
once I get to where I'm going
then the homeless guy gets pissed at me
I don't [ __ ] live here you know
it's cheaper than the fine
this guy's dead why did the one who cut
you up
I fell down that's why they wanted to
cut you up look at Willie Barcena is
going to heaven because he didn't even
know he was an angel yet the Willie
Barcena yeah he was just in the news
earlier right what happened he was
choking another comedian again allegedly
allegedly so your Instagram yes because
somebody had a plan to draw you fleeing
the scene of look of the comedy and
Willie Barcena telling you go bro go you
gotta get out of here Holtzman you gotta
get out of here now and he meant it and
I felt the fear you know I felt that
this situation was getting out of
control
well we'll listen go back Willie Barcena
what happened over there bro chaos bro
chaos what they want to be a mob row
leafblower joke broke that's the first
time that happened to another at the
common street you got it yeah you were
you get into a confrontation
my Lords oh yes his bodyguard knocked me
down Willie Barcena with the nerve to
run it was a miscommunication I take
full responsibility for that because the
body God has to the body God has to
appease his boss protect again he has to
he can't wait to see what the situation
is he has to just take so maybe he
thought I was gonna somehow injure
Martin Lawrence that wasn't the case but
you know a body God can't take any
chances
anyway
it was like a cartoon you know seeing a
cartoon where the the the Pluto gets
punched across three tables and goes
airborne just like that I kid you not
the guy's a professional bodyguard
he could have ripped my nose he could
have detached the retina he hit me right
here on the right side of the face
straight shot man and I went up and over
the tables airborne and then hit the
ground and the first thing I said was I
can't [ __ ] up the show you know I got to
leave I got to get up and leave I could
have faked it you know people will call
me after that the People magazine was
calling me they wanted to people they
thought I should sue and all this other
[ __ ] you know I don't want to be part of
Martin Lawrence it's [ __ ] creepy
movie thing you know he gets in trouble
every time he has a movie that comes out
of some [ __ ] you know they may be
shooting guns in the street make one a
to some [ __ ] you know I said I don't
want to be part of somebody else's
[ __ ] fucked-up life you know I could
take a punch in the face it's not the
first time I got punched in the [ __ ]
face probably won't be the last and
after you get punched in the face by a
professional bodyguard and you get up I
mean it's almost like a badge of honor I
mean you know I could take most people
keep probably [ __ ] be unconscious I
picture you for lying bro laid matrix
tiles and landing on a very comfortable
level who are you saying I got off the
stage I made the mistake to get off the
stage and I saw a Martin Lawrence you
know you can tell it's Martin Lawrence
because Scott is his ears have ears I've
never seen such big ears on a mountain
Lawrence before and so I knew it was him
and he was in the club for some reason
smiley from HBO was there in the back he
said it was the most amazing thing he's
ever seen in his whole [ __ ] life and
so I went over to because they were
[ __ ] with me you know they were
[ __ ] heckling and they were [ __ ]
with me so you know I was at that point
where sometimes that happens and I got
off the stage and approached him and the
body God has to just think he's you know
he has to be the bodyguard even though I
had no violent intentions whatsoever
and bam and I just picked myself up and
said no this is show going on here don't
[ __ ] up the show cuz you got [ __ ]
knocked out [ __ ] like a gentleman
yeah just take your [ __ ] lumps go
away and come back another day maybe
don't leave the [ __ ] stage you know
so I take full responsibility for that
would you go out after there's a parking
lot to hang out with Julian I got on
that rail back at the rainbow but that
marathon my cheeks right here this is
where it happened right here and this
was swollen I was just close to going to
a [ __ ] doctor that's how many weeks
it was a ball but I look at it like it
could have been a lot worse
I mean your nose could have been flat
your [ __ ] idea retina could have been
detached your throat could have been
smashed - the guy was professional just
straight none of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know how amateurs hit people
straight and the guy was a brick
[ __ ] - it big is all [ __ ] hell
you know but what are you gonna do it's
a comedy foot the [ __ ] you know you you
know it's like doing this podcast you
asked me to be here and I showed up I
hope it goes well I hope people like it
I don't know but it's good to see you
dog with you like you like any other
comedian bro they were they were with a
Joe Rogan and begged to be on bitched
and screw the whole story for the likes
or do it like try to give us something
I'm not saying just Joe Rogan but any
other podcast right be off the back
there man you just think I hear you get
up
[ __ ] you took him like a soldier don't
just get up and it wasn't the first time
there was my fault anyway no I got
[ __ ] it was one time another time in
the Air Force in the barracks when I was
bothering this other guy I was hopped up
on coffee medicine I was being [ __ ] I
deserved it I was then this guy had had
enough he was from LA and he
around with a right hook and I was on
the carpet on the carpet in a second and
you just get up and you go wow that's
what it's like to get [ __ ] hit walk
back to your room and you're kind of
embarrassed but you know you deserve
didn't you take it you just take it but
it's it's an amazing feeling to just
[ __ ] hit the carpet in like a second
one minute you're walking the next
minute you're [ __ ] picking yourself
off the [ __ ] [ __ ] so I will always
remember that one those are the two
biggest ones and then my brother J bit
me it's all good so comedy right have
fun have fun jeez damn but when you
finish these shows these big shows you
do do you just want to leave I never
understand the sign in the UH
t-shirts and the CDs you know don't you
do you really want to see the people
afterwards isn't it better just to run
away I like to shake their hands I like
to meet them you don't get you don't get
you like it somebody give us two dollars
this guy lives loves getting fisted
what's Brian's favorite story short
penis or a Mitzi shore Mitzi Mitzi
she passed you yeah Mitzi passed I'm
into the audition Oh quite a few quite a
few five years it took me to get over
there I remember right under some crazy
[ __ ] out there like like Peter
Chan
Oh Peter Chan yeah he didn't know how
funny he was no he was so funny you're
hilarious man just crazy boom shot but
I've seen him doing print ads and stuff
he does other things you don't yeah boom
Shakalaka still there selling is a
garage sale items on the on the patio
yeah boom Shakalaka bro how's the other
one man the other guy huh Oh or meaning
oh yeah hyper river I'm a river I've
been rubber with a bodega you still
there he's dressed like a scientist
right yeah paper plastic bag yes people
running Nick we look we'd yeah but that
the store is hoppin now we were to look
at brought somebody game five bucks
world regal Kiki Lisa's Pappy um we use
their the Comedy Store cuz I know you
used to go there a lot and I'm I will go
there a lot Monday nights too but you
read there were numb remember when Billy
went now when I won't see the black
light but yeah I started on with Fat
Tuesday how big - oh God
Fat Tuesday yeah and then the main room
and they had a Farrakhan there everybody
there you did that show - huh I never
did that show I thought you did it that
was a hot show to get to do how guy
Torry I started always guy white guy
they let you that show is that old guy
John John Honest John you know they
loved him they wanted to suck him off
that Honest John they couldn't get
enough oh I love that [ __ ] Honest John
he was blowing everybody in the back you
know Honest John gave me show and he'll
suck you off
it's very funny but that was hard to get
a show on that but you did chocolate
sundaes oh no I didn't do any of that
either
I got a I'm not you know Filipinos me
you know this show business you haven't
you know it's common you have to you
have to you have to put yourself out
there you have to ask you know I have a
problem asking [ __ ] you know
it's the personality problem you know
yeah be a [ __ ] go gather you have to
be a networker you gotta be willing to
swallow some some semen wanna swallow
any semen [ __ ] you I got nothing to say
I got nothing to say I'm not I'm not
good at making conversation you know
what I mean just to make conversation
you know if I come up to somebody and
they don't say nothing and I'll say
something I'll start to say something
like you know and the padai don't get
anything back then it's over [ __ ] you
you don't wanna [ __ ] ask me about
mating [ __ ] you am I supposed to ask you
about you for [ __ ] five minutes [ __ ]
you you know so it's a tough game you
know that's why I was so you gonna do
flip ace podcast cuz you know we go back
and he's genuine and he's genuine
there's no there's not well some of the
other comics I guess don't think so but
you're very genuine genuine and you're
very honest and there's there's no
sleaze factor I told another comic that
once that guy Steve Byrne you know Steve
yeah he's funny I like Steve Byrne and
there's no sleaze factor in him he's
just you don't see anything else no
agendas no no hidden hidden
psychological [ __ ] problems roll
crazy but you know what there's no
hidden favour right no right there's no
loyalty in the road didn't favor for you
right we're carjacked how your first
time here I got carjacked over in Silver
Lake one of those predominantly
neighborhoods and oh that was I was in a
convertible Mustang and sure enough when
they point the gun at you you [ __ ] you
got a do it but they [ __ ] say if they
say come over and suck my [ __ ] thank God
he didn't say that he just wanted just
wanted with a leather jacket I was
wearing in the [ __ ] car and they got
it that you were in French so luckily
you know is your Johnny it was what was
that guy mouth Eric Madigan remember
Eric Madigan it was we were coming from
Cynthia Levine's house at that time it
was in the daytime damn and they've just
pulled up behind me
it was you know you just do what they
say and hopeful that they don't fight
took your leather jacket yeah it was a
nice one it was like baby veal real soft
yeah it wasn't even kept in the cage it
was right from the birth sack they took
this baby veal right from the birth sack
and made the jacket fresh fresh this is
back was Silverlake was not the way it
is now like not a hipster but this was
back before when it was dangerous who
carjacked you a hipster Hussein got
jacked oh yeah who did a friend of mine
who did Jack the pest Moby they should
be a lot of gangsters and sober late
teen took the truck and everything
pointed m16 that that yeah that's what
they must have been they must been part
of a crew cuz there was more than one of
them and they they just pulled it right
up and before you know it the gun is
right there you say fine take it I got
it back the car yeah it was the Mustangs
you know has had problems you had to put
this to get a shifter just right or else
it wouldn't start so they probably and I
got that [ __ ] car back in a fairly
good condition there was a lot of food
papers in the back you know various food
places that you know that they like to
eat so what did you do you just you just
jumped out of the car and just stood
there
run like yeah no we didn't run they just
took off they wanted the car and they
were gone it's no wall it's just a car
in the leather jacket I don't know if
Ike I don't sure you see the rainbow the
cops the LAPD drove us home and they
were nice enough to show us on the way
home how they treat people and then you
wonder why people don't like cops when
they know hey look what we're gonna do
to these guys you know you know we're
gonna [ __ ] are we what is this
Blade Runner what the [ __ ] just take me
back to my [ __ ] apartment we
yeah you know [ __ ] crazy crazy that's
crazy Megan carjacked huh [ __ ] dude yeah
get up the car all right you gotta ask
me nice so what's your Instagram
Instagram is uh what is it hashtag Brian
Holtzman and my Twitter is Brian
Holtzman was taken so my twitter is uh
hashtag is it right hashtag Holtzman
Brian at yeah at Holtzman Brian that's
hol TZ I mean yeah I just paid about $80
and they're gonna give me like 60,000
followers that I don't [ __ ] know so
I'm excited about that you know I want
to get up to speed you know because I've
been on at about two minutes you know so
I'm going through this company and
people think I'm popular you know maybe
I'll get some road work can you book me
I have a lot of followers you don't have
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't have [ __ ]
you got money to pay for that
everything's that come job today so
you're genuine you got the audience you
blew up you got it all the way it was
supposed to be you know you didn't
manufacture anything and that's why I
love you man I just that's why I gave
you that t-shirt thank you bro I still
owe you two hoes man I keep it real bad
I gave you two t-shirts yeah this was
that that's a crazy mustache cuz you
know I'll pay him forward cuz I don't
like no offense I know your culture
really likes t-shirts I prefer a collar
on my [ __ ] shirt you know call me
what I you know I I don't have the body
for a t-shirt you I have tits so are you
saying you're gonna use these t-shirts
as currency or as like a regifter
oh yeah these are being
goodbye you know how many listeners
right now you're making sad no no so
enjoy a Central Park yeah that's a nice
shirt that's the Central Park New York
what we're gonna do bi do bi I have to
check my phone maybe three or four years
ago that place is off the chain Carly oh
no no I I went as a tourist I didn't
want to ruin my vacation by doing comedy
yeah I want to relax when I go on
holiday Felipe hates to waste a vacation
like not doing comedy Wow guys they
tagged your sponsor Dubai if I had a
following like Philippe Philippe then
that would work you know it's just to
talk to a bunch of strange people in
Dubai about we're just wondering how it
is over there like you did especially at
one time Jeff bodean looking especially
the sound he said the sound was no good
oh my I didn't even get a copy of it I
got five grand and that was it you know
it's the story of somehow how it works
out sometimes you know you were working
you were working on it for a while right
you were right what they say how you
were workshopping it huh you were
putting us [ __ ] together right your act
together
yeah I was gonna do it you know I was
gonna try to do it right you know get 45
minutes find it you know on dududu what
I needed to do to do it well sure do
that again oh yeah I want to start a go
fund to have people support my bad ass
because I don't want to I don't want to
spend ten thousand or $20,000 or $30,000
on a special that nobody wants to buy I
can't do that I can't take that chance
I don't trust [ __ ] show business that
much and I don't trust myself no lip
he's gonna go oh we're gonna have to
leave it it now after coming over now
you stupid [ __ ] what happened to
you man
how to stay out of show business by
Brian Holmes before didn't write that
book about a theater show businessman
what happened at their mad tbo dishes oh
that's another funny [ __ ] story
what the [ __ ] I was probably told me I
had he said Philippe I've always thought
I would talk about you to this lady
Linda Wright from MADtv when I got there
one time she mentioned that Bobby Lee oh
and why will you mention you well hey we
told what happened man I go there it was
before I had to go to work so I was in a
particularly great moon it's probably
coming from my rails the night before
well you know I'm not in the greatest
mood so am i my manager at the time was
Rick Siegel he got me to audition so I
went in and there you have to do three
characters so yeah I want a monkey [ __ ]
around with three [ __ ] characters so
I go in there and I I was mad what's
MADtv so I thought they would get it you
know I thought they would get it I'd go
in there and man they did not [ __ ]
get it they call the [ __ ] manager
they said how did you send this because
you know did that time is so special
that time can't be wait whose thing is
that are sucked too good at this show
ladies for long Mad Dog I start
screaming kind of like yeah Andy Kaufman
sort of thing right yeah Ana MADtv
second or second character though
I don't know I'm not good at I'm not
good at being tested that's the problem
so how long was your madness before they
still cut it wasn't terribly long I
wasn't late for work
right you had a MADtv edition bro yeah
yeah yeah
so I've had my chances so I can't take I
take full responsibility for my station
in life we're all here to play the role
that goddess did you say God you don't
say god you're gonna do you we're all
here to play the role that offends
people we say god that offends people
today you know everything that's
offensively anything so we're here to
play the role that God is sciences right
now God is I guess mad at me and this
assigned me this podcast [ __ ] whatever
somebody teach a [ __ ] comedy show cuz
they wanna [ __ ] you have to the [ __ ]
show you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's looking
nice she just taught you to park you
know [ __ ] the comedy show real brother
to see that they destroyed our a heckler
nominee [ __ ] was destroy that's
just a heckler with the whole rotation
of a stroll to start the second show
right after this the headliner ain't
going no bro
sometimes you were enough or you were
[ __ ] now mom
my name is he I'm an economist he I put
on a show he put me on your bone you
know after Bobby yeah I had he had me
play an angry audience member well I
remember that were you saying I was
complaining about him and just talking
[ __ ] something about you what he's
saying work hard is some [ __ ]
nonsense and then I stormed out no yeah
they wanted me to audition for that and
I told them once again I said once again
I said Carlos knows who I am if you can
find someone else to do this go right
ahead I'm not going to [ __ ] audition
and that's that and yeah because then
that takes the casting directors job
away and they don't want that they want
to be part of the [ __ ] mix you know
they don't like when they get when
someone tells them to stand down we
don't need you be huh hell yeah you
broke it these breaking it down it's
like how it like it like it even when I
when I when I convenient throw you're
boring cause you got the rope rope but
but they still call you and could they
got to go through the mat formality they
were gonna have drinks like each other
our necks in the row and then he threw
the scrip you know the jury got the roll
but the cast it could they booked the
casting director she has to prove that
she had a job Don Barris didn't put me
in his movie Windy City he did you hear
about that movie nah he wanted to have
lunch he kept saying I said I don't need
lunch I'm not hungry I don't need what
you know you want to put me in the
[ __ ] movie just put me in the [ __ ]
movie why do I have to have lunch with
you I know I have to carry my own lunch
I don't need your [ __ ] lunch you know
who wants to drive all the way to
[ __ ] Hollywood have lunch just put me
in a [ __ ] movie so I think I didn't
appear in that movie Brian I really
liked the idea of this how did how did
not be in Hollywood oh yeah what the
party short movie - addition for that no
that was that was that was a given no
the first one Paulie is dead well he's
not dead yeah you and that one yeah just
a short part I play a homosexual gay
prisoner trapped in a woman's body and
incarcerated against his will very very
morose very sad but I nailed it I nailed
it
you know I took what I could from what I
had and I just [ __ ] nailed it I
nailed it
can't audition but if you give me the
pot I'm a lady
oh yeah once you know you have it once
once everybody's behind you and you just
do it you just do it and now everything
is on digital it's none of this [ __ ]
that you kept hearing oh it's so
expensive it's on film at your expense
now they can all [ __ ] themselves it's
all digital we can do a hundred and
fifty [ __ ] takes we can spend it Oh
all day and he ain't gonna cost you
nothing [ __ ] you know you know all
that [ __ ] is over you know it's so
expensive order to film the film the
film [ __ ] you
I know they would do every four minute
or man this guy man you're costing us
money it's a red cap [ __ ] enter
[ __ ] when we leave right you know who I
miss miss Mosley's Marilyn she was good
[ __ ] did you know Marilyn Martinez she
was the best cuz she she said exactly
what was on her [ __ ] mind a lot of
the Latino comics they didn't like that
cuz no one ever took him to task before
she just told them and I wouldn't
mention names but she told him and they
always said no Marilyn she's dirty
well she don't say that like that book
her in the show says she's too dirty or
joy a coke was too dirty they just
couldn't follow that she was funny man
Oh God she looked at a guy goes mad
balls I wish I had a big fat thing with
you my legs just to put on your lap sir
can you feel well you watch a TV and I
just take my date me to your ear yo
you're [ __ ] right good just from end
that was that so you was there the brave
boy when she knows a big big fight then
Brenda Martinez they know I was glad I
was okay because I heard it was ugly
I told whoever I told I said Marilyn
wouldn't have liked that but I heard I
missed that I missed Carlos Mencia and
Joe Rogan go at it in the o.r I missed
that I'm happy I wasn't there for this
[ __ ] these events you know you know
who you had the Marilyn Martinez was
awake awake at the Comedy Store you were
there you made fun of the of that was uh
that was uh that was Freddie sewed
already so toes yeah I apologize but you
made in front of that one dude there was
a virgin remember I would have [ __ ]
them yeah yeah yeah I was there too I
wonder when you were when you spoke he
goes mad other guys coming up here at
their new here talking about [ __ ]
nicknames [ __ ] nicknames
I said I met Freddie the first time I
met Freddy he was in the parking lot
stealing and stealing a stereo out of
the car yeah
did you a party with Freddie
no just Johnny Sanchez and I thought we
were done talking about Johnny when joy
[ __ ] Jeff out there you weren't there
either what is that keep freebase is his
mustache very good very good anymore
Rick Ramos he's funny too he tells me go
slow in the beginning go slow I said
Rick I got [ __ ] 15 minutes there's no
time to go slow what are you gonna take
your time please Rick Ramos jelly bean
yeah so man so so you can actually have
a if for me to put on a special I'll
share it man I like to watch it
someday I'm looking forward to it
something's got to give you know you
gotta like you know you got they can't
why do people buy this [ __ ] detergent
soap because it's on the [ __ ]
television people can't buy what they
don't know exists as simple as that
so how you do that that's what has to be
done I'm convinced I'm too young to go
on the road and play [ __ ] paddywhacks
in the [ __ ] laughs Fox laughs Hut in
the [ __ ] mall in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere it was 11 for the winter
road yes I was just stupid I was working
for United Airlines I got a week after a
Comedy Competition in Sacramento laughs
unlimited and like an [ __ ] I don't
take the whole week off well I think it
was two weeks most people would take two
weeks off know this [ __ ] drives all
the way from San Francisco to Sacramento
does the show and then comes back goes
to work then drives back to Sacramento
and does the show and then drives back
for a [ __ ] a week then the guy said
where's your date planner where's your
date planning you know
they years ago they'd say where's your
you had to have a package yeah your
package I said god I can't show him
anything I show me anything I'll never
get hired you want to see a tape boy see
my tailor DVD resume right he said
where's your date book I know what the
[ __ ] he was talking about then he
realized he wanted to probably book me
again so I've been a [ __ ] since the
get-go you know no no no one tells you
how to do this [ __ ] no man you gotta
learn huh remember that book remember
that comedy book you were trying to sell
you for $100 without the Booker's yeah
remember that vaguely oh yeah yeah yeah
that's stupid silly [ __ ] yeah Dante
Dante and Shang were selling it
I saw Dante he was at the memorial yeah
he's a manager now some kind he I think
he manages the Jeremy yeah so how would
the memorial you were there just be yes
and they had cameras and that was all
filmed and that was wonderful but who
knows what that you know where's that I
don't know why they had all those
cameras what's gonna happen are they
filming it for home movies or what the
you know what the [ __ ] you know so uh
yeah they had they had the old-timers in
the main room and then they had the next
generation in the oh ah
and so that was fun look when the last
time you hosted the potluck Oh long time
long time I stopped doing our [ __ ]
host the parlor it was [ __ ] party man
if you're not going up ready we're gonna
we're gonna have a bunch of
professionals going out first then a
bunch of people woke up the morning team
the [ __ ] party yeah [ __ ] here who
drove on Jersey for this [ __ ] spot
man admits he's not even [ __ ] here
today yeah what's the long who bumped
you like when you when you were starting
this toilet Oh Eddie Griffin bump me
Eddie Griffin Wow aces yeah I went and
saw Eddie at the Rio in Las Vegas and
Thomas Ward is doing really great
Thomas Ward is really solid if you know
Tommy he opens up for uh he had Richard
Pryor's son work in the show but he
they've axed him to not do that anymore
and another guy but he's got a room at
the Rio and I went there and watched
Eddie and it's just you know he said he
Griffin you know then he only does that
during the week and then he does the
weekend show with the other you know the
tour
yeah the tour Lopez yeah and so I got
bumped by yeah you know just about
anybody who walked in you know it's a
pecking order
people say oh Holtzman how come they
they don't put you up earlier because
it's a pecking order you don't
understand what's going on here
it's television it's movies its Fame its
fortune and that's who gets to go up
first you [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of my
face
you lose that it's a pecking order okay
they can come in and bump anyone they
want they don't even have to be funny
whatever this fool be on stage and then
he'll see was it a bad Buy
[ __ ] your wheels later I passed by now
real estate he's a chancre a banker a
sheriff he's every [ __ ] thing a
realtor yeah oh yeah you know anything
you think you know he's a bricklayer you
know he hang sheetrock he does it all
he's [ __ ] unbelievable he's good 21
HBO specials coming up no [ __ ] wheel
wheels he's got the car you know he's
he's he's right you don't tell the truth
and show business people ask you how
you're doing you tell them I got all
this going on Holtzman will say Wow
you know bright Callen
rest in peace what happened there what I
guess huh
it lied okay yeah he's something what's
so cool
was it next show laughs ask me next show
is 11:15 at the Comedy Store on Friday
night tomorrow night no are they room
and 112 30 on Saturday night in the main
room
I'll close the main room out so summer
laughing someone everybody's watchin the
show man check out Brian Holtzman this
Saturday right Friday and Saturday at
the Comedy Store
Friday Saturday at the Comedy Store get
that book up bro how to fail in
Hollywood check your check your check
your local and then one time I was
drinking some woman from NBC invited me
to her office in Burbank to read for
something and I was drinking Budweiser
cans 12-ounce before I went in I want to
smell like a [ __ ] brewery I don't
know that probably didn't [ __ ] go
over too good you know what happen we
took that homeless go home oh not good
clogged the toilet and stained the couch
ain't all the food the comments are
haunted oh that's [ __ ] if you think
you know this haunted missus just you
know give me a break
I'm a Roman Catholic can you're talking
to me about spooks and spirits and
[ __ ] ghosts get the [ __ ] out of here
Halloween Halloween's once a year now
get the [ __ ] out of here any agents in
the house hey this buzzed about to fall
out can you cover saw it back on no you
bro yeah that's that's a big problem
they just did so many shirts that they
produce in a day and then they just
instead of sewing it on like you would
if you were not them
anyway Hugo shows coming up yeah man
July 6 tonight I'll be at the skipped
town theater 9 p.m.
also July 7th I'm a free to fastest
Saturday I'll be doing say set at 8:45
p.m. and that's Riverside and then July
10th be blows jokes Fox Theater downtown
Riverside 8:00 p.m.
Yemen right holds me close not The
Comedy Store on Friday and Saturday go
check out my Tyler watts Oh boom those
midnight shows are fun those late shows
can be really fun like to end off your
night you know and go say hi to Brian
thank you you know before he runs out I
said everybody consider hi there I'm
hired a Brian man and they don't charge
it if you get there around 11:30 or
something they'll let you walk right in
you don't have to charge so you cheap
people but it's fun because Comedy Store
is great cuz you can sit there and have
a drink on the patio and maybe some snow
Jamis people and then no no I figured
you know I wanted to give after that
liver transplant they recommended that I
give that up twice oh yeah Mickey Mantle
what's up what's up fool podcast we're
back and we come back next week we might
not have a podcast next week oh that's
good thank you Brian thank you for
having me buddy at the weakest